6
25 on your wednesday morning what's
driving you crazy how about three
complaints in one viewer beverly's got a
lot on her mind first she's concerned
about
speed writing please slow down on alta
charleston and far hills and she says 2
15 in summoner parkway in the morning
it's like the indianapolis 500
second she writes about out-of-state
plates either go home
or learn to obey our speed limit you're
not in california anymore
register your vehicle dmv is open and
third she's got a twist on drinking and
driving telling bartenders
don't serve drunk people beverly you're
preaching to the choir on all your
points speeding
never a good idea i will continue to
bring up unregistered out-of-state
plates in our conversations with police
and nhp
and i would hope that bartenders err on
the side of caution when it comes to
cutting off customers but
what do you do when drunk drivers wear
their own bartenders in the comfort of
their own homes
thanks again for riding beverly buckle
up drive carefully please put down the
phone if there's something driving you
crazy email me traffic eight eight news
now dot com